and following a detailed outline from
health highly
lighting the continuing pressures on our
hospitals and icu departments
and the emergence of the highly
transmissible variants
the executive has agreed that the
current restrictions will be extended
for a further four weeks until the 5th
of march
2021 the restrictions will be reviewed
on or before the 18th of february now i
appreciate that
this will be disappointing to many
people listening to us this evening
i think particularly of those who are
feeling the pain of separation
from loved family members and friends
for workers
and employers who are worried about
their livelihoods
and indeed parents who are juggling the
education
of their children with work and other
responsibilities
separate arrangements have been in place
for our schools
outside of these regulations and the
executive will have a comprehensive
discussion next week
around schools returning and of course
the broader education issues
this is undoubtedly the most difficult
of times and we know the sacrifice that
you're all making
to save lives and as an executive we are
committed to
taking every possible step to move us
forward out
of this pandemic we have invested in the
development of a robust and effective
vaccination program
and in a highly efficient contact
tracing service which has
a 24-hour turnaround in 93 percent of
cases and both of those services
vaccination and the contact rating are
the envy of
other jurisdictions our uk four nation
partnership
has delivered medical support for our
hospitals from our armed forces
a national vaccination program that is
world leading
unprecedented funding which has proved
invaluable across all facets
of our society and the establishment of
genomic testing which will be crucial to
the fight back
uh in relation to the new variants at
present
we estimate that the uk is undertaking
40
of all uh genomic uh global sequencing
so we're pushing ahead with our work on
a pathway to recovery
the covert 19 task force are going to
bring recommendations on the approach to
a relaxation of restrictions to coincide
with our review in february but in the
meantime we're asking people to keep
going
to follow the public health advice stay
at home as much as possible and remember
if we all work together
and we do it we will get through it